yeah
this Russian tank is having a makeover
Ukrainian troops now in command
Russia's Retreat from the khakif region
is being captured in celebratory
pictures
one soldier who's part of Ukraine's
offensive described what he saw
it
[Music]
foreign
the military volunteer showed us what he
said had been a base for Russian troops
on the edge of the city of isium
abandoned less than a week ago
this place was where Russian soldiers
came to fix their vehicles you can see
here The Zed marking what was a Russian
military vehicle clearly the ukrainians
knew that as well and judging by the
enormous hole in the ceiling and the
devastation all around they struck this
place as part of their counter-offensive
that pushed the Russians out
they fled in a hurry
so this is where they used to live
hey
so there's jars of what look like
pickles or something
um there's bits of clothes all over the
floor
we've seen a prayer book as well
boxes of ammunition were also discarded
Russian Russians Russians
[Music]
Ukraine wants the world to know its city
is back under control
the significance of the win even marked
by a visit from the president
flanked by his Commanders
ium is free but it's hurting after
months of War
a cluster bomb killed Yuri's wife
the suffering is everywhere
this man uses a wood stove to heat tea
and soup for the few neighbors who
stayed in his apartment block through
the Russian shelling
born so
how to fix a country while still
fighting a war
Ukraine has no choice but to try
Deborah Haynes Sky News isium